Bernard Montiel c'était quoi ton
résultat travaillé un jour
[Rires]
c'était soit chanteur vraiment faire
plaisir comme ça est-ce que tu as faim
tu as faim bien marché à l'époque ça
fait comment déjà absolument fou de vous
absolument
donner un jeu de mots ça fait quoi la
santé même absolu des mots une pile à
mon cœur pour pas mourir tout éteindre
d'amour
je ne sais pas
fais gaffe je vais filer un gars là en
fait je reviens dans mes frères mais toi
tu étais le temps tout ça international
naviguer dans tous les pays pour la fête
nationale
c'est pour ça qu'il est pas agent secret
agent pas secret
journaliste et écrire des livres et
voilà le jour où j'ai écrit mon premier
livre j'étais pour avoir des rêves comme
ça
et l'hôtel de faire du cabaret je
comprends l'autre qui va être agent
secret elle doit être journaliste
ce que je suis tu vois
être beau intelligence seul sur scène
c'est bon rêver d'avoir fait le Stade de
France
je les fais c'est l'année où j'ai
rencontré et Clara mais dis-moi j'ai
l'impression quand même
non mais le jour où m'a regardé ce
jour-là j'ai été euh
tout à l'heure
bien sûr non
merci ce que je sais c'est que c'est
très agréable d'entendre ça de la part
de quelqu'un qui a connu tant de femmes
qui a eu ce succès
Daniel parce que en fait il s'est rien
passé c'est pour rigoler
comme ça et du coup c'est vachement bien
parce que pendant mon animiste France
tous les vendredis et samedi soir on
allait dans toutes les régions faire des
galas de danse donc du coup j'ai un peu
touché du bois ça ou alors vétérinaire
et aller sauver des animaux qui ont à
moitié brûlé pas vrai ou les chocs
pétroliers puis aller nettoyer les
oiseaux
nettoyer des iguanes des missions
Porsche Cayenne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau mais aussi je dois être
vétérinaire mais non
[Rires]
allez sors allez c'est vrai que c'est
l'invité c'est vrai que c'est la vie
c'était quoi ton rêve parce que me dis
pas que c'était ça
non comme j'ai un peu le physique et
l'esprit aventurier j'aurais aimé être
Tarzan explorateur dans la jungle alors
avec les deux
ça ouais
trouvez ma gel oh comme ça
tu vois pas que tu jettes tout le monde
normalement ça te ça te convient pas
l'esprit de tenir oui
être chanteuse fantaisiste comme Annie
Cordy et là quand je suis comme ça j'ai
l'impression et donc c'est pour ça
peut-être
[Musique]
non mais je chante
vraiment faire partie du cabaret
que moi ça me va c'est ce que j'adore en
fait
là on a une conversation
mais pas plus quoi il y a pas le kiki
que j'ai respecté
mais il y a non mais c'est quelqu'un de
très bien hein
donc voilà peut-être pas ça t'arrange ça
ou bien c'est pas ouf ben non ça
m'arrange pas non mais simplement voilà
c'est la vie mais j'avais pas c'était
trop moi c'était trop rapide pour
l'instant je sais pas dire je suis tombé
amoureuse là et je suis pas en train de
faire vivre un chagrin d'amour donc ça
doit être d'accord
d'école qui est dans un c'est génial
c'est important que tu fasses des amis
je suis désolé
[Rires]
désolé c'est vachement bien c'est
vachement bien j'ai une bonne nouvelle
Cyril je suis à nouveau libre donc
tu dis ça pourquoi tu as des vues sur
quelqu'un ou pas pour vous parce que
vous étiez chafouin là tous ces plans
[Rires]
voilà non non on verra pour l'instant
c'est pas l'ordre du jour on va trop
vite toi c'était quoi ton rêve moi
c'était footballeur professionnel
après ils sont dans la dépression
j'y arrive pas c'est une vraie peine
quand tu penses que tu vas y arriver que
tu t'es prêt tu dis pourquoi pas et tu y
arrives pas c'est vraiment après tu t'en
fous après tu dis bon bah c'est pas
grave
je t'avais été footballeur professionnel
tu achèterai pas des voitures avec
185000 km
[Rires]
est-ce que vous avez fait la
distribution il y a des gens ils
achètent des voitures neuves il se
posent pas la question tu vois elle a eu
combien de propreté 6 c'est tout
tu as raison
fait attention c'est pas mal Géraldine
quoi
en fait je sais que les les jeunes enfin
les garçons qui avaient vraiment un rêve
de sport que ce soit du tennis du foot
et tout ils en rêvent encore même après
aux alentours de 50 ans
de pétanque
à chaque fois la nuit j'ai l'impression
d'avoir perdu mon cochonnet non mais
sérieux
[Applaudissements]
écrire des bouquins comme Valérie
réaliser des films j'ai à peu près
réussi mais j'aurais voulu être Coppola
donc ça c'est raté j'aurais bien aimé
être Gabriella
l'argent
elle était championne
[Rires]
exactement et moi j'étais très fort très
jeune je vous jure que c'est vrai ok
j'étais genre j'avais le niveau je vous
jure que c'est vrai quand je jouais
genre je vous raconte un jour j'étais à
Deauville il y avait Louis Fernandez qui
est venu et genre j'étais sur le central
et genre tout le monde disait c'est qui
ce gars qui joue c'est monstrueux il
avait 10 ans et jouer genre voilà j'ai
tout le monde veut dire tout le monde
regarder ma mère elle était comme une
folle c'est mon fils et mon fils
regardez c'est un truc de ouf c'est tout
ça c'est le nouveau Nadal c'est Nadal
c'est nanas et ma mère est comme une
folle ouais mon père aussi et donc plus
Fernandez la jouer avec moi tout ça et
après donc comme j'étais à Paris et il
cherchait un moment il cherchait un
sparring pour Gabriella sabatisme
exactement parce qu'elle cherche des
joueurs donc en France donc il te
propose qu'il propose à des mecs qui
jouaient entre 5 6 4 6 pour une femme
voilà
et donc ils m'ont demandé d'être
sparring donc grosse époque de Gabriel
ça une époque s'est fait graphique elle
liftait de ouf mais oui
tout ça et après elle a dit oui je veux
jouer avec lui
[Rires]
on a joué ensemble tout ça et un moment
je vous dis la vérité
elle est à la volée elle fait un smash
et je me prends la balle dans les soft
c'est une vraie info
et donc j'arrive et donc lâche comme ça
et là gentillesse
cela fait ça
et donc elle arrive elle commence à
masser les cheveux
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je lui dis alors j'appelle ça
veut dire c'est quoi ça je suis en
sparring comment ça me masser les seuls
c'est quoi ça s'est pas sérieux les gars
moi j'ai un pour jouer au tennis bonjour
on est ici en train de me faire masser
les sauf elle a dit ouais elle arrive
elle baisse mon champ comme ça
et elle prend des balles et elle les met
comme un
[Applaudissements]
mais je n'ai jamais raconté de ma vie ça
va être pris par tout en Argentine
de 203 non